yo tout le monde sait squeeze il est
dégueulasse et aujourd'hui comme promis
on se trouve sur une nouvelle vidéo sur
garry's mod alors cette fois c'est pas
le mode murder de la dernière fois c'est
un nouveau mode qui s'appelle le mode
pro open mais je pense que beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent déjà je vous
explique très vite fait il ya deux
équipes l'épreuve center et les rôles
s'inversent à chaque nouveau round au
début de chaque round les preuves sont
trente secondes pour se transformer dans
n'importe quel objet de l'amap est allé
se cacher et au bout de 30 secondes donc
les hunters vont pouvoir se mettre à les
chercher et leur but c'est de les
trouver et de les tuer pour gagner la
manche avant la fin du temps et je crois
que le temps est 2 et voilà c'était le
brief peu mieux du monde j'espère que ça
va vous plaire et désolé c'est de pire
en pire
bon visionnage bon thé vert ou un indice
jeu dans un étage du rez-de-chaussée et
pas ceux ci flare t4 - là alors j'ai
fait une petite construction
il a bougé a fait bloquer mon gars
[ __ ] de chaises de herde
tu as la discrétion coup admet qu'il
110g la pire cachette
il va rentrer ce soit bien fait une
chose en plus et n'ont qu'à attend comme
en avait pas su bloquer apparemment de
la voir avec al jazeera même là moi je
partais lui quoiqu'il eût bien cachés
l'accord sélection mais bon c'est sympa
au dessus vas-y saute saute aux yeux
c'est encore vasys août atteignant
allait tu vas y arriver mika bout de la
table où la table c'est la table et
bouffi a pas de faire au aulas il s'est
passé un truc là aller où la bad ne
sortirait pas les bougies pitch est
tournée cela devait rentrer mon garde
est resté immobile et dialectes le coin
en haut je sais que tu es par la ego
attention non pas partie d où une simple
chaise
alors cette droite celui de gauche celui
de gauche c'est quoi la poche pour vous
c'est ça la gauche mais pas trop long
c'est qu'à savourer les dix ans aux
mécaniques avions fait un truc drôle
vas-y on va chacun d'un côté mika
l'iccat est grillé incité la ville à
basile h un petit bruit mika pour
l'aider à nantes ans a pas commencé si
c'est bon vas-y lâché un petit bruit
mika
là
allez fais du bruit ça la paix n'avait
pas ajouté venue sur moi comme un gros
chien on sait qu'il est ici des lavières
les québécois vient pas un truc mika
vient d'y cavic a été chaud ou pas tu es
prêt à courir au nom au nom d'un vieux
mec il s'est barré chez sur le cul la
haye là tu voulais faire ce que tu vas
messieurs à levi avec mon gabarit
trouverez les meilleures gâchettes
passe-t-il à temps voilà je veux une
centaine au fond tellement drôle mais
est est ce que pour la 20e fois hugo et
une barrière tire les pin pon sur le
chihuahua si vous savez
tu vois à l'uqac duquel était comme un
vigile mon gala à paraître raide comme
un ballet quoi où et il m'a fait
sursauter hoya allez allez allez bien ok
cette fois c'est bon déjà il ya un long
télé white boîte cherche pas je les
remets le téléphone j'avais vu par terre
j'ai senti waits mais t'es citron plus
résistants de la planète
kg dérange pas c'est trop haut mais
thema ya du sang mais y'a pas son
critique adam d'orange de lâches
j'ai pu sur trois avoue lia teaser de
pervers qu'observent les gens faire
leurs besoins même à aa
mais pas deux fois mais même s'il n'y en
a pas de téléphone et 5k mais toi ça te
fait y'a pas de téléphone est ici une
feuille salue une bouteille à bouger
oui toi au online et la ola ok alors là
alors là c'est la mort du stylo bille
qui t'attend moi j'ai le droit
si moi je suis tout seul et quand je
suis un connard je suis certifié connard
donc j'ai l'autorisation b toinon non
j'arrivais à vous et vous allez mourir
pourquoi pas le savez je ne sais où j'en
étais sûr j'en étais sûr m'arrête à
bayal vitres à la va-vite monsieur
monsieur ya de 8
oui bah attendait monsieur attendez
attendez monsieur monsieur monsieur
micro j'ai une canette pour toi je veux
bien tient alors tiens je te la donne
gm va j'ai une valise pour toi tiens
j'ai une valise tu la veux je tiens le
coup tu viens au pied tout de suite
hugo tu viens ici hugo tu viens ici et
tu prends à tanger trouver un trait je
te laisse cinq secondes pour te cacher à
l'ego tu viens tient à temps je me dois
te cacher voilà merci voilà va le
chercher
random mouillac magal noir
pourquoi moi on voit tout de suite à le
haut des attentes éternue c'est ouf
enfin attention il faut pas être ton
post est faux de région c'est déjà la
fin de cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous
aura plu je vous souhaite de très bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année d'avoir deux
superbes cadeaux de manger comme des
gros porcs et ont fait un chèque de de
quoi du 2-2 tchèque du nez le tchèque le
plus salaces n'ai jamais fait c'est un
record